Airbnb I think Airbnb is properly rated
I think Airbnb is one of the more
interesting things that's happened in
the last 20 years have you told somebody
30 years ago that they're going to let
strangers live in their house instead of
hotels who would have been laughed out
of the room it's kind of like bottled
water imagine telling your
great-grandmother that people pay four
dollars for bottled water when it's free
in the [__] sink I also think on the
flip side it's a mature thing now it
probably hasn't had as much of an
overall impact as it could have so I
just think it's kind of properly rated
to slightly underrated last one
pickleball I think pickleball might be
slightly overrated right now and I'm a
pickleball owner I literally just flew
here from a pickleball tournament
similar to nfts similar to AI when
there's something new first it's
extremely underrated and then when it
flips it gets overrated real fast
because everyone's like it's the fastest
growing sport pickleball is nascent it's
tiny right now I think it's upsides
enormous but I think the hype's ahead of
its reality even though I think in 20
years it has a chance to be one of the
sports that's like real real but I'm
taking that angle on this part